فتاح عائلته تخشى على سلامته في
الوقت الحالي يقولون إنه داخل السجن
لا يشعر بالأمان وهو ما
يتدهور نفسياً ، فأنت تعرف
شريكاً للولايات المتحدة.  المواطن السعودي 1980 مو
الولايات المتحدة وطلاب الطب يعتقدون
أن هناك طبيبًا ينتقل إلى
المملكة العربية السعودية في عام 2006 ، وبطريقة ما في عام 2017 تم
اعتقاله مع كل هؤلاء الأمراء
ورجال الأعمال السعوديين من قبل ولي العهد الأمير محمد
بن سلمان الذي وضعهم في فندق ريتز كارلتون
ولكن  نظرًا لأننا نسمع من
محاميه ، يقول محاميه إنه لا توجد
إجراءات قانونية عادلة تنطبق على قضيته وأنه
لا يعرف سبب احتجازه في
الواقع ، كتب المحامي إلى وزارة الخارجية
الأمريكية في يناير من هذا العام ، لقد قرأت
لك هذه الرسالة  أن محاميه كتب إلى
وزارة الخارجية في يناير / كانون الثاني ،
وقرأ دون تفسير أنه
نُقل إلى سجن سعودي حيث
احتُجز لمدة عام تقريبًا ، حيث
سُمح له خلال ذلك بقليل من الاتصال
بالعالم الخارجي ، ويُعتقد
أن د.  لقد تعرض هاتاكي ولا يزال يتعرض للتعذيب
النفسي على الأقل خلال فترة
سجنه ، ومن الواضح أن الأسرة
قلقة للغاية بشأن سلامته ،
وقد قال مستشار الأمن القومي جون
بولتون إنه كان هناك من الولايات المتحدة.  الوصول القنصلي
إليه جيدًا حتى هذه اللحظة ، ما
أفهمه هو أننا حصلنا على ما
يسمى بالوصول القنصلي ، مما يعني أن
الدبلوماسيين الأمريكيين في المملكة العربية السعودية قد
زاروه بعد ذلك ، وليس
لدينا في الواقع أي معلومات إضافية في هذه
المرحلة.
يقول اعتقاله إنه ليس الوحيد
الذي يُعتقد أنه تعرض للضرب
أثناء احتجازه في فندق ريتز كارلتون
وأنه ليس السعودي الوحيد
المحتجز في الوقت الحالي دون اتباع الإجراءات القانونية الواجبة
دون اللجوء إلى معرفة سبب
احتجازهم.
اشتهر بالوقت كمتحدث تحفيزي
ليس فقط الطبيب في المجتمع
ولكن متحدثًا تحفيزيًا وشخصًا دافع
عن الحقوق المدنية داخل
المجتمع السعودي